one time Besh Stein was among the
world's leading instrument manufacturers
but then it lost much of its shine in
the past few years though Besh Stein
regained some of its former prestige
Georgian pianist dude animus Manish Vili
is paying a visit to the bass teen
Center in Berlin
she had her debut at New York City's
Carnegie Hall in 2006 she's been a fan
of Bestine grand pianos since her
student days to assist their porn sound
it's the Bel Canto sound which you
rarely hear anymore
I played many westerns and always for
the same reason first and foremost a
piano has to sing it can't be a
percussion instrument it has to be an
instrument that sings I'm in Shenzhen
and anything in this instrument
pianist and composer Franz Liszt played
on instruments by Bechstein in the 19th
century this one was delivered to him in
1862 a hundred years ago Bechstein was
selling about 5000 instruments a year
off today it's about the same number
there were slumps and high points in
between
car Bestine founded the company in
Berlin in 1853
besh Dean had its headquarters and
workshops in Berlin later they also
opened a production site in London the
instrument soon gained an international
reputation
now Besh Stein has its headquarters in
the steel vac design and office center
in Berlin
but both the upright and the grand
pianos are built in the small town of
scythe hennas DAF in the eastern state
of Saxony a grand piano takes a full
year and about 500 hours to make the
heart of the instrument is the
soundboard it occupies the space in the
middle of the grand piano and amplifies
the vibrations of the strings this is
where we dry the sound boards of all the
best ein concert piano we use only
Italian spruce wood because it's the
best word for our concert pianos the
concept instrument again it is during
the manufacturing process each piano is
given a thorough going-over by a machine
that plays up to 50,000 keystrokes in 20
minutes
the final touches are provided by master
craftsman Matthias cleansing duty the
are vital part of my job is adjusting
the Hammers and I was just doing that if
I had to try to express it in numbers
I'd say that determines about 40 percent
of the sound of a grand piano in French
music professor Ann condom has come to
purchase instruments for her
conservatory she says she's very
impressed sit think is still it's a
question of the balance between the
sound and the keys and these create the
best equilibrium between the quality of
the sound and the quality of the key
action distortion Bechstein exports its
pianos to countries all over the world
the most expensive ones cost over a
hundred thousand euros we a call from
Moscow we don't try to buy up America's
we don't try to buy a pianist we want to
win them over and we have institutions
tend to have a little less money so
they're not our most important customers
our most important customers are
individuals
a Bechstein grande once had the same
reputation as a Stradivari violin here
in berlin they're hoping to regain that
lofty praise from pianists around the
world